been at it 40 years yeah we're still
finding parts that need to be healed but
it's natural ask these questions of that
place in your body and wait for the
answers to come do you have something
you want to explore
um my guest today is a psychotherapist
who created a very interesting and
effective therapeutic modality called
internal family systems or ifs it's
quite a radical shift in Paradigm you
left all that in the past not realizing
you were locking away exileing your most
precious qualities Dr Richard Schwartz
Dick Schwartz Dick Schwartz ifs yeah
it's incredible big shorts and stuff
maybe some of these parts are bad can we
not label that as something pernicious
that we need to you know override and
and and overcome you can but it hasn't
been working that well this is a real
inner family that we we all live with
it's like your external family if you
neglect them